le début de mes recherches sur madame
desbassyns on remonte à l'époque où
j'étais professeur d'histoire et
géographie lors de mes sorties
pédagogiques au musée de villèle j'étais
chaque fois frappé par la réticence de
certains élèves à entrer dans la
chapelle pointue et à s'approcher de la
dalle funéraire de madame desbassyns il
faut dire que ce personnage décédé en
1846 doit sa célébrité à une mémoire
orale et à un imaginaire collectif qui
en ont fait une véritable diablesse ces
dernières années j'ai pu consulter des
documents d'archivés qui montre que
cette image de madame desbassyns ne
correspond pas exactement à la réalité
du personnage et qu'elle relève en
grande partie du mythe et de la légende
le mythe donne une représentation
déformée de la réalité comme ce portrait
de la femme autoritaire méchante et
cruel avec ses esclaves mais il reste
crédible car la discipline était
vraiment dur sur le domaine de madame
desbassyns et aujourd'hui encore son nom
est évoqué pour qualifier un employeur
soupçonnés d' autoritarisme envers ses
salariés avec la légende
en revanche on entre dans le monde de
l'irrationnel des croyances et des
superstitions le monde dans lequel
madame desbassyns est une créature
diabolique qui n'en finit pas
d'expliquer ces crimes dans les feux de
l'enfer du volcan et d'août ont dit que
son âme revient parfois hanter les
vivants
le mythe négatif de madame desbassyns
apparaît plus d'un demi siècle après sa
mort
mais il plonge ses racines à l'époque où
elle même et sa famille défend des
dépositions monarchistes et cléricale
dans une france de plus en plus gagné
par les idées républicaines et laïques
dès le 19e siècle cette famille a ainsi
cristallisé autour d'elle les rancoeurs
suscitée par sa position sociale élevée
par son immense fortune par son
influence politique et religieuse
la légende de la créature diabolique se
développe surtout lorsque les
réunionnais apprennent l'histoire et les
horreurs de l'esclavagé dont madame
desbassyns devient en quelque sorte le
symbole
elle n'était pourtant pas la seule mais
la plus grande propriétaires d'esclaves
de lille mais une femme chef
d'entreprise au 19e siècle
je n'étais pas courant pour l'époque et
cela pourrait expliquer bien des choses
voilà donc les principaux thèmes que
j'ai développé dans mon livre